what is my unique strategy or what is my
strategy of doing that I think where
I've been very successful is I just do a
lot of stuff and eventually something
works I think there's a few things in
marketing I'll say three things that I
think are simplistic simplest you know
world but number one how about just
singular goal Facebook did it appszoom
accom has done it and I think with even
recently with my dork world and helping
people overcome fear and start
businesses I'm kind of like having a
bunch of goals I'm like here's our
tick-tock goal here's our Instagram goal
here's our email list goal here's our
organic traffic oh here's this I'm like
what is our most important goal and as I
just even pick one for some period of
time and so I think I've come into that
realization like let's just pick YouTube
and just be okay with that and guess
what that'll rise all other ships so
don't be ignoring the ignorant of those
other ones but just focus on one second
thing is that as I was doing a lot of
this content recently which has gotten
me really fulfilled and it's it feels
good feels great is youtuber okay dork
calm mostly YouTube mostly in YouTube
world the second thing that's been most
critical and this is really hard because
everyone does it says they do this or
wants to do this but doesn't who who is
my audience who is the audience that I
really want to be helping and
communicate with because on one hand I
want to I want to connect with like nine
figure CEOs and ten figure CEOs and I
you know I actually don't think there's
a lot of content of how to go from seven
to eight or eight to nine and I can
share how we do it but that audience is
really small and they don't really know
as much help and so we've realized like
our audience is dudes 25 to 40 that have
tried to start a business that haven't
been accessible that are afraid of
failing and need a little bit of help
and so I think the second part of
marketing that I've gotten revisiting is
Who am I really trying to talk to and
what are the words so like here are some
words that we've even identified that
our audience resonates with rat race
freedom so I'm like really alright
self-doubt so those are some of the
things that I'm thinking about in the
third part that we're we're thing
anything that's applicable for every
businesses what is your unique strategy
of success like so with that we have two
parts one what's our core messages that
we're this is
YOUnique like bread and butter that you
will know I was like what through meat
about this and he's like what did them
it you have so many messages just pick
three so I was like alright challenges
to overcome fear million dollar weekend
and behind the scenes of Annie figure
company that's the three that we're
gonna do and that's it and then the the
second part is they say that again so
those three are the three what does
recently let's take a step back so one
what's your goal pick one goal number
two who is your customer number three
what is your core messages that people
know you for so for me those are the
three that I'm gonna be known for
challenges which I always tell people do
the coffee challenge which is take it
ask for 10% off when you buy coffee
you're gonna be afraid you're gonna
learn about yourself and you're gonna
grow secondly is behind the scenes of
any for your company so like how do you
like that there's not a lot of people
that have that experience and I can do
that and the third part is how do you
actually get a million dollar business
or $100 you know a million dollar
business start in a weekend which I've
done many many times and I can share
which is unique and then the last part
of this marketing equation that I think
I'm exploring and revisiting around all
these things is what is my unique
strategy or what is my strategy of doing
that I think where I've been very
successful is I just do a lot of stuff
and eventually at least something works
but I think I will be even more
successful slowing down being a little
more thoughtful with these things and so
our unique strategy lately has been do
the fast stuff but on lower risk items
so basically tweet and Instagram and
LinkedIn post everything like
throw it all out there unlimitedly
and then based on what works a lot
aligning to our core messages that's
what will go deeper and that's what will
write a blog post about that's what will
do an interview about that's what we
will do a YouTube video about and so
it's just having a higher likelihood of
homeruns and how would you hi Sean the
mic like you look like a therapist yeah
really feel you're almost 40 I'm I look
and feel 32 but I'd say I'm about in
physicality in our society 38 and that
physicality in our whatever traditions
of 38 ok cool even years I am 32 and I
look and feel 38 so you do look 30 a bro
I'm trying to go the other way so
and I would love so if you were 21 again
21 no network no name-brand you're
starting up from scratch and you don't
have to go the same pathway you went I'm
curious you know if you had the luxury
of picking any path now that you know of
so many more paths and you probably knew
about when you were 21 what path would
you go down honestly I think I copy my
path which would be what so you're 21
what do you do I'll tell you exactly
what I did I didn't know what the
to do so I wouldn't tried a bunch of
stuff out to figure out what to do I
think the only I think one question is
what Delta would I have chosen and I'll
tell you exactly what that was
so at 21 I didn't know I didn't know
what a BS was I got it got it from
Berkley I was like Oh bachelor science
is cool
everyone kind of follows a stream right
like when you graduate from college
which I think less and less it becoming
important everyone's like oh get a job
go to Intel go to wherever and I was
like ok I guess that's what everyone's
doing but I've always wanted to start my
own company I didn't know what to do and
so I think the two things that I did
really well when I had that day job at
Intel was I use that as my investor and
the two things I'd recommend is that I
started a lot of businesses so if you're
like I don't have any idea two things
you can do one go to San Fox comm and
start a newsletter and send an email
once a week for 365 days or for 52 weeks
that's number one or number two go on
YouTube take the rhein holiday challenge
and post a video on YouTube for 30 days
start there the second thing that I did
is that I connected with people very
aggressively and I asked anyone I knew
for anyone that they knew that was
really smart
that's how I met Tim Ferriss that's how
I met Orin Hoffman dave McClure James
Hong Max Levchin ramit sethi I basically
put on events
I hosted lunches I organized conferences
I didn't know anyone but I wanted to
bring smart people together so if you
don't know any smart people find one
smart person say hey you should meet
this smart person and then just go and
hang out with both of them guy and girl
guess what you coulda done zoom if
you're in remote country or if you don't
have any connections I think one of the
ones I've really observed lately every
person I've hired that's been the most
impressive has done two things they've
offered something for free to a value
that I've wanted and they did it without
asking and those people live in the most
impressive and guess what now they're
like hey I want to meet this person I
want to do this thing I want to grow
here and like that most of them are now
working with me and so I think I would
have that was something very early on I
was very aggressive on meeting people
and just trying to build my brand in
terms of career I think the two thing
one thing I did very well is I was
really great about following my
curiosity and things I was really
excited about so I really loved Facebook
and I really love the mint and I was
like I'll do whatever it takes to work
there um I think the only difference I
would have chosen is find someone 10 to
20 years ahead of me that I think is
doing the things I would would like to
do in 10 to 20 years and be obsessed or
aggressive in figuring out how to make
them excited to want to be a part of my
life so I had one guy dug her she was my
boss at Facebook and it didn't really
work out as well for as a mentorship but
it's nice because like you can say oh
that's how you do a relationship oh
that's how you do a career and it'll
shortcut it you just have to figure out
the real most important thing is how do
you get them to give a about you
and the best way to do that is help them
with whatever things they're working on
so you want to hear something crazy
Shawn I don't know if you know this but
I don't know if Noah knows it but I
launched my I created my so my company
which is a it's an okay company it's
been good for me it started because Noah
had a blog post about organizing
conferences and I was like I what was it
called it was called like how I made how
I made 90k hosting a conference of
something was that it Noah mm-hmm I made
a coordination conferences because I I
didn't know I was gonna make money to
him yeah so I saw that and I was like
well I had a book club at the time and I
was like well I didn't mean I've been
hosting these meetups but I don't make
any money from it I should like make
money off this thing and so I started my
come
and he have made millions of dollars
personally off conferences because of
that blog post and more importantly or
maybe not more importantly I've met I
met actually all three people in this
call and most of my friends and
co-workers do because of that blog post
because of that blog post I meant
Neville because of that blog post
Neville the best man my wedding I met
because of that Katrina so so what
you're describing of what you would do
and how basically you describe like
hosting events and which is similar in
the same vein as posting content I did
the same thing and it made me millions
of dollars and I met all my best friends
that way awesome I mean I think the only
other thing that I was doing at the time
that I think everyone should do so
number one build your brand in some way
even if you're not trying to be a
personal brand I think practicing
writing is a skill you can use in sales
you can use development you can use in
design you can use it almost literally
forever
I think the connections very valuable
literally probably the reason I'm a
multimillionaire is because I've been
able to meet and help people and connect
people connecting and meeting but the
third thing was that I was starting a
lot of businesses and I think what's
beautiful is if especially earlier in
your life your cost of living is sodium
low and my cost of living is still damn
low because I'm I haven't grown up in
some ways and I'm maturing in certain
ways that it's so low that you should
take a lot of risk very early on in
trying a lot of things out so I like
when I was working to Intel I was doing
this college consulting I did a thing
called ninja card comm I was putting on
these conferences that I charged for and
then I was working at mint I started
doing the Facebook apps like it all
plays games and I started making a lot
of money but now I was working at
morning I was working on weekends I was
working at lunches we're working at
nights I was working I kept going and I
kept trying a lot of me and eventually
after probably two and a half three
years
good to know four and three or three
years later my side hustle finally
became my main hustle
you
[Music]